well I grew up in Hillsdale so the
college was always in my backyard my
grandfather John Wilson taught history
for 31 years at Hillsdale my parents
were alumni my early education was also
in the backyard of the college I went to
Hillsdale Academy from kindergarten
through 12th grade where they just
prepare you for that liberal arts
education so Hillsdale has always
defined home for me in that sense of
family church and local community I was
attracted to what the college taught and
the good the true and the beautiful as I
was in high school and I was really
passionate about athletics I was
starting to realize that this could be
part of a collegiate journey as well and
coach Gravelle was quick to find me he
asked me to consider playing and I
started to believe that I could and I
committed as a junior in high school and
was so grateful for that the best
description of freshman year was
spinning in circles and not just because
I was a middle blocker and that was part
of my movements on the court but because
I really was trying to orient myself
I think after freshman year and maybe
the sophomore slump I was really finding
myself comfortable on the collegiate
court so coaches Chris and Stephanie
Gravelle have been a husband-and-wife
team at the college for years and what I
think is so unique about their capacity
as coaches is that they demonstrate to
their players
what a unified team can achieve my
proudest moment without a doubt is
setting school records and going to
Nationals and I feel spoiled frankly
that we got to do that my senior year it
was everything we had been working
towards but we got to savor that feeling
and that was just a real gift
so I met my husband at Hillsdale I
actually scouted him out before I was a
student
growing up in Hillsdale there's one
Catholic Church he was Catholic I was
Catholic and I saw him and his head was
you know tall enough for me we have four
children we have five-year-old twins
Bridget and Lucy a three-year-old Marie
and a one-year-old boy named Knowle yes
I am homeschooling right now the twins
who are five are in kindergarten loosely
and I was drawn to it because we have
moved
most times including just a couple
months ago middle of the school year so
we're striving for some stability well
if there's one thing I can express to
the college it would be gratitude they
have made me who I am they have shaped
me and they have guided me along every
step of the way so I can I look at any
accomplishment and say that I have
achieved it it was through these coaches
and these teachers and these teammates
and by the grace of God that I achieved
any of this it takes a team and that is
truly how I walk away from my experience
as a college volleyball players I was
part of a team
you